I guess we could end 20:19 on a high
note with somebody that has never been
on the show before but somebody that
you've referenced many many times yes
ladies and gentlemen you've heard Jim
talk about him before he's the master of
the knee walk
he is mr. Bob Backlund Bob Backlund mr.
Backlund Franklin oh he's hugging the
little great just give him the wireless
look at him all the ladies get out hard
he's a strong man yes he is mr. Backlund
who you yes to me it's good to see you
it's mics not on it's like something is
Mike's not on his mics not on one point
maybe next year we'll do a thing where
we you need a mic yeah that up yo no
we're good
[Applause]
we turned it on there you go mr.
Backlund where are you going no I'm
going I'm just right here I'm staying
here I'm not going anywhere I promise
you that you said there we go there we
go I'm already gone mr. Backlund I don't
know if you realize this but you know
I've been a wrestling fan for a long
time I followed your career forever Jim
Norton over here not as big a wrestling
fan however when I asked him who is the
person that you admired as a child it
was always Bob back it was Bob back and
every single time mr. Bob Backlund
that's true isn't it yes how's that grab
ya he's a very very strong man now and
then it was later on I started using the
crossface Chickenwing to make them give
up I gotta go crazy we're getting
requests for baby for baby Frank well I
thought the baby from Porter do you want
to do it do you want to get the
crossface Chickenwing a plot to you or
no thank you
make him look like tailored ham he said
sure yes yes of course there's never
been one Wireless Oh God okay don't hurt
him mr. Backlund when he says
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
now rich aren't you sorry you said no
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM f
[Music]